feels like the last time I made a video
about this exact topic was like 2 days
ago it was September 29th oh boy that
was when I was talking about layoffs at
Epic and this time we are talking about
layoffs at Bungie and also just like the
broader things happening I wanted to
wait a little while to make this video
uh just because I wanted to talk to a
bunch of people I spoke to friends who
worked at Bungie and especially after
like my last video was so uh just
passionate SL emotional I want to just
make content every time somebody loses
their godamn job like what an awful
feeling but I did want to take the
opportunity to dive into this deeper I
have made a short about it uh but let's
go a little harder today we're going to
talk about the layoffs at at Bungie and
talk about Destiny specifically because
I um feel so strongly about Destiny in
so many directions I used to play a lot
of Destiny I have not played in a while
which is probably part of why this has
happened a lot of EX players like me
have stopped playing the game but I
think there are maybe things that the
games Community doesn't really
understand about playoffs sometimes and
I also wanted to talk a little bit about
what we can do about it so I spoke to
two separate people who have been
organizing unions in the games industry
we're going to talk about a bunch of
stuff okay first up
obviously case you missed the news
somehow around a 100 people were laid
off from Bungie supposedly due to
Destiny 2 underperformance sourcing IGN
here who said they had an internal town
hall meeting been last Monday that
impacted multiple departments addressing
a round of layoffs and Bungie CEO Pete
pons allegedly told remaining employees
that the company had kept the right
people to continue work on Destiny 2
which wow what an awful thing to say I
don't know if you were trying to be
comforting by saying that but did you
for some reason not think that would go
public there are people involved in this
who moved to Seattle to work for Bungie
uprooted their whole lives and now have
nothing and no job and just nothing for
the hard work that's what kills me about
layoffs are awful they are happening
across a lot of Industries right now and
I think it's only going to get worse in
the games industry I'm aware that this
is not exclusive to the games industry
it's just the industry that I love and
have dedicated my whole life to so
that's the one that I'm talking about so
for Bungie specifically I could repeat
everything I said in the video when I
made it about epic which I'll leave a
link to Below in case you didn't see it
which is basically just that it sucks so
bad and um my heart breaks for all of
these people and it's just a passion
that goes into game development to have
that just be discarded as though it is
valueless I guess because it is to a
corporation it's just so uniquely brutal
anyone with any skill that would qualify
them to work at a AAA Studio like Bungie
could make more money doing something
else working for a different company
with that same skill set you work in
games because you love games you put in
long hours because you love making games
and you love your team and you love the
community and so for the companies to
turn around which of course they do I
get it like it's not realistic to assume
that because you love your job that you
get to keep it but that doesn't make it
any less heartbreaking they just lay
them off they just get rid of them
totally discarded despite the sacrifices
that people have to make to get there in
the first place and it's just GH it's so
hard to think about but again
all of the sentiments I shared in the
epic video are the same there are a lot
of concerns that I have about the
direction of the games industry across
the board about games of service about
monetization about subscription Services
I'm going to make a video by advertising
cuz I'm increasingly very very concerned
about that I think I last touched on it
maybe 2 3 years ago but I think that is
going to get a lot worse but we're just
going to be like a little bit more
factual here today though I did want to
address some things I've seen people say
on the internet so uh IGN confirmed
reports that Bungie took responsibility
for the layout rather than laying them
at the feet of parent company Sony pass
installed employees at layoffs were
largely due to underperformance of
Destiny 2 over the last year as well as
lower than expected pre-orders for
upcoming expansion the final shape which
is a tough one cuz it's like well if
you're not performing then yeah you kind
of have to make Cuts somewhere it's
really frustrating though in the case of
Destiny 2 because Bungie is so good at
what they do in terms of like I
genuinely think don't know if it's a hot
take they have the best firstperson
shooting mechanics consistently
obviously they partly pioneered them not
totally but partly reinvention if you
will and Destiny 2 feels so good to play
there are just so many other issues that
um made a lot of players tune out I
think in the particular case of Destiny
2 and this is really just my opinion
never should have been free to play I
think that was the wrong decision to
make for this particular game but we
know that player engagement was
massively down and recent Revenue goals
have been down by I think it was 45 or
48% and so for now it seems like they
are putting
a ton of work into the final shape which
has been delayed to June 2024 Marathon
also being delayed to 2025 uh and has
been in development since 2019 employees
were also told that Destiny 2 player
sentiment was in an all-time low which
I'm inclined to agree with and SS to
tell IGN that this issue had been
repeatedly flagged to leadership for
months before the layoffs with employees
begging for necessary changes to win the
players back which again is why it sucks
so bad you can have the people on the
ground the dev team be like this is
clearly what this game needs please
listen to us and still have the
executives the people in say no and then
the community gets mad at the developers
even though the developers are the ones
who are advocating for the community
that's like literally their job in a lot
of cases the people who work in
Community Management Lanna ret was their
Community manager who I think is a
fantastic person and is so dedicated and
so in love with uh Destiny she was one
of the people who was laid off she was
100% the person who was getting screamed
at every day and advocating for players
to have it be ignored and then get laid
off like that's the reality of the
situation other than that employees also
told ignan that they felt really
frustrated with the layoffs given the
company had just completed work on a
brand new headquarters which was more
than double the size of its previous
office Parson was pretty heavily
criticized for this tweet saying today's
a sad day at Bungie as we say goodbye to
colleagues who have all made a
significant impact on our shudio what
these exceptional individuals have
contributed to our games and Bungie
culture has been enormous and will
continue to be a part of Bungie long
into the future which is certainly true
but it's also like damn if only you you
didn't you didn't do the thing you you
did you know the teams that were hit
were community art engineering
recruiting legal audio QA creative
Studios and it with impacts across both
teams and those impacted thankfully are
receiving 3 months of severance and
Cobra health benefits and I just so
badly hope that they all land on their
feet and find new positions but to
expand there are two things that I
really want to say to audiences I have
seen so much and I hate to even validate
this stance but it is a stance I've seen
so much of well the game sucks these
people deserved it it is a fact that uh
Destiny is being played less and enjoyed
less there are issues with Destiny which
again so much because the core of
Destiny game so good and I am one of
those people I stopped playing Destiny 2
after playing tons the reality is the
people who are laid off and have their
lives impacted here are not the ones
that are responsible for the decisions
like I said they knew there is no way
that these people aren't advocating to
improve the game aware that there are
issues with it everyone who works in the
games industry wants to work on
something good I'm sure I've said that a
million times before it's not something
like freak accident that people who work
in games want you to like the thing
they're working on badly they don't
think about money when you are making a
game you're not thinking about how much
money you're going to make or what the
monetization strategy is that is so far
above your head that is the executives
that is the suits that is culprit the
people who actually make these games
just want you to like them and every
time that you don't like them it goes
what the hell am I doing this for put
all my soul and all my energy and all my
time and all these people move to godamn
Belleview to work at Bungie they want
you to like the game and while layoffs
yes happen across multiple Industries
this isn't a unique thing I think the
blame is going to the wrong place from
everyone that I know who's worked at
Bungie and I'm trying to be careful to
speak about this very hot right now I'm
not trying to like get news out of it
but the 12 separate people that I asked
about this unanimously across the board
100% told me that they had shared player
sentiment and expressed that that they
had known that players people like me
even a lot of the popular Destiny
YouTubers people who've been loyal to
Destiny for a very long time were no
longer happy with the product they are
very very well aware of that these devs
who've been laid off and they passed
that on that was forwarded and shared
repeatedly and they got laid off anyway
the people who wear the fancy suits
still have their jobs and this is a
thing about the games industry that
drives me nuts in terms of the community
the relationship between the games
Community the journalists and the devs I
said this in a recent video I think I
said this in my bald's gate video it
really really really should be the three
pillars there against Publishers this
like ecosystem we have of the players
yelling at the journalists the
journalists yelling at the Players the
players yelling at the devs the devs
sitting in silence is so much useless
noise that accomplishes nothing that is
so convenient for the people who
actually making the decisions the bad
decisions the ones that we don't like
like it's so convenient that you go they
deserve to get laid off they're making a
trash game we don't like the game right
now this is just not the truth it can't
be 100% rate but the people who work on
these games are aware of the product
they're making and are doing their damn
best and are probably fighting the suits
wish that we would be better as a like
video game culture about applying
pressure to the right people it just
drives me nuts to see that kind of
rhetoric when it does not work that way
so there's a thing that I realized like
I had a disconnect on before I started
working in depth so I'm sure a lot of
other people do too when you see layoffs
and you go oh they deserved it oh the
game sucks the game is only going to get
worse we talk about budgets for video
games the budgets are really just
salaries the game cost $250 million vast
majority of that money is salary also a
marketing budget office expense budget
but most of that is actually just people
so when there are layoffs what you are
directly seeing is a budget cut the game
is having its budget cut the game
usually still has to come out at the
same amount of time because they still
have to meet their quarterly earnings to
literally stay in business it's just now
with less budget so anytime there are
layoffs and people are like good
game developers which is like just the
most absurd thing again so convenient
for the people actually causing the
problems not saying all devs are perfect
it's just why are we doing this the
disparity there is so extreme basically
what you're saying is yeah make cheaper
games make the game worse there are less
people working on it it has less money
put into it that is what a layoff is no
matter what the game that you are
playing the next time after layoffs is a
cheaper version of the same game you are
basically like arguing against quality a
layoff is a reduced budget they don't
have as much money to make good games
anymore that sucks that sucks for you as
a player that's a thing you should care
about if you care about the game or the
studio that face layoffs and the fact
that this is happening across the
industry year with have been so many
good games and I keep seeing all these
comments being like good old games suck
now are you high out of your mind we've
had so many Fantastic games this year
anyone who says good all games suck now
in my opinion does not play many video
games and he just like pretending to you
are a fake girl gamer okay video games
are really good these days there are
some examples of bad releases buggy
releases and bad monetization policies
but across the board 2023 a lot of
great video games I my only
conclusion can be that you don't really
play many this website is called
videogame layoffs.com comment is being
routinely updated and the current
estimated total of layoffs is 6,500 that
accounts for Unity and epic pretty major
layoffs Amazon as well EA embracer group
I would bet that Unity is going to have
even more layoffs and it's broken down
by company type and this part really
concerns me a lot 20% console 20%
publisher 22% online Indie AR and VR
have had way less and of often go hand
inand to be perfectly honest like this
is such a good case for indie games and
how well frankly players are supporting
indie games like that's only got better
over the years but the fact that mobile
is so small very strongly indicates to
me that all of the companies that are
seeing this on Console are going to want
to go here that means that there is more
growth in the mobile market and more
money in the mobile market layoffs in
the games industry and your attitude
being good all games suck now it is only
going to make them worse if you are
unhappy with the current state of video
games but you still love video games
these statistics are extremely
concerning for anybody who likes the
console PC market you like a AAA action
game if you like anything that comes out
of any of those big Publishers you
should be super concerned about these
stats not happy about them because all
of these companies the way that they
operate on the market have to go okay
how do we stop this they can't just go
indie or go AR that doesn't work by
definition certainly can go mobile and
pivot to mobile Dev and that is
something that I worry about more and
more often you can like gloat and be
happy that game devs are getting laid
off but you can't tell me you like video
games at the same time is essentially my
point being happy that people being laid
off is like happy that they entire like
system that you love I presume is dying
in front of you please just if you have
any emotion always direct the anger at
the people with the money and not at the
people getting laid off and the you
like being devalued right in front of
you know there's some more detail here
and it is super interesting when they
have the exact Studios that have face
layoffs and how many what kind of games
they made but uh yeah great resource
lost updated on the 9th very much
appreciate video game layoffs.com for
showing this and another facet of of
this number of this 6,000 500 that I
think is like a pretty big deal in 2023
again I already have the video where I
like speak to this very emotionally if
I'm speaking to this in just like a very
factual cold way even there's a real big
human cost for that 6,500 people who are
getting laid off and then seeing all of
their friends or peers at other
companies get laid off are going to
leave the games industry not all 6,500
some of them will find jobs elsewhere
but I have had friends who've been laid
off over the last three years you've
said I'm done in gaming I'm not doing it
anymore and for every time that happens
too you are losing experience
experienced people you are losing them
for good we are only having Juniors able
to join which is great for people who
are up and coming but not great across
the board when we have so many senior
roles that needed to be filled in so
many of these companies with every round
of layoffs we lose people who will never
come to the games industry again we lose
their years of expertise passion and
their hard work and their enthusiasm
that should be a loss that you again as
a gamer I think should feel you are
losing when people get laid off as what
to do about it look I don't really know
the answer to that question but I spoke
to some people who have been organizing
videos game unions there are a number of
them CD project red is one of them they
actually work to form the Polish Game
Dev Workers Union which was in response
to layoffs at CD prodct Red it's open to
anyone working anywhere in the games
industry under a polished contract
although it currently only has a company
commission at CD prodct Red they said
they started talking about unionizing
after the 2023 wave of layoffs and this
event created a tremendous amount of
stress and insecurity affecting our
mental health and leading to the
creation of this Union in response so
part of what they're doing with their
Union is is more security transparency
better protection stronger voices and of
Crisis Mass layoffs are a danger to Game
Dev industry and they 100% are we
believe that unionizing is a way for us
to reserve the industry's potential the
union said its priority was to give
staff a voice in company decision-making
with a view to increasing employment
stability which like seems like a win
for all of the employees it also wants
to help workers voices be heard on
working conditions on the long run and
the union Founders actually said the
studio had been making great strides in
improving working conditions especially
in eliminating crunch which is huge and
awesome and we love to hear it
especially considering how well-received
f pH Liberty has been and this is such a
good case for that so they said there
was no crunch certainly not to the ex
same extent with the base game there
were overtime hours for those willing
pay it or taken his vacation days
meaning that they get the time back if
they spend the time and the entire
development of phantom Liberty has
proven that when you treat an employee
well he gives more of himself and the
end result of his work is better that
translates into higher quality product
Trade union exists to maintain this high
standard of working conditions and
improve those elements that could be
better and that's a thing that like
really makes me feel strongly about the
positives of these unions again as
someone who like just doesn't know much
about unions that the quality of games
there is also going to be better if
people aren't overworked over tired
overstressed agitated with one another
knowing they are protected not panicking
about losing their job the quality of
the actual releases has a chance to be
better as well it's just better for
everybody across the board that is most
of my case here is just to say to people
saying the worst stuff in response to
this which people have been doing in my
own comments section they deserved it
games suck nowadays anyway make better
games don't be lazy Debs you are getting
mad at the wrong person and shooting
yourself in the foot if you actually
like video games the layoffs are really
bad for you so
scared of every Studio that I love going
to the mobile market I'm so scared of it
happening and every new round of layoffs
I'm like is the industry I love is
there still a world for the industry
that I love and the games that I love
they not going anywhere anytime soon I
don't mean to fear manga it's just
thinking about the future you know I'm
concerned about the direction and
increasingly so this year
6,500